I think there's an unequal but a lot
more care in their appearance and that
side if they thought I would however I
would go as far as to say that I think
women on the whole are more virtuous
than men when it comes to relationships
but maybe a controversial thing to say
but I do think that it's the truth
especially at the younger age brackets
mmm I think I put in more effort overall
like from that how how many girls do you
know that have cheated on men versus men
they've cheated on girls cuz I know it -
the 1 or 3 to 1 ratio gay men - what do
you think the motivations are different
between why men cheat and why women
cheat yeah so yeah I remember who it was
some relationships guy saying men cheat
because they want sex or they want
variety women cheat because they feel if
not attended to enough so here we here
we go
have you let me use the Family Guy
analogy before oh yes is my favorite
analogy that I use for dating there's a
lot of we live in I [ __ ] love this
Rice's are clearly quite its marker so
anyone who's watched Family Guy before
Peter is stood at the window watching
Bonnie who's Joe's wife out of the
window he's got binoculars he's looking
at it and changed out the window and
he's making like under his voice going
like she's really hot so I'm making
money through me and then Stewie comes
in he walks along to the sign he goes
what are you doing fat man looks of it
he goes looks out to the window he sees
Bonnie getting changed he goes I don't
understand you've got this smoking-hot
wife at home why would you be looking at
oh I see it doesn't need to be better it
just needs to be different and the value
of novelty in a relationship of
something new hmm cannot be understated
biochemically speaking as well I think
it's it we can get onto that yeah the
genetic lottery as its world yeah but
the value of novelty can't be
understated it doesn't need to be better
it just needs to be different and I
think that's so much cheating from men
can be explained by that so another is
hyperbolic discounting
so cheating is the reason people cheat
from my perspective from like a
behavioral perspective is its failure to
see the the power and the value of a
long-term outcome long-term cost of
benefit and not being able to discount
appropriately with a short term short
term positive for long but also I think
like especially guys the number of the
guys who I knew it was like cheated and
like I've even thought about cheating
and I cheated it's it's the narrative of
they are better different more
interesting funnier more attractive
whatever but I just think there's a
fixed trajectory the relationships take
and it's just starting that a process
again like month one month two great so
because I'm at there's so much stuff
that we can go into here I'm gonna let
you do